moi j'ai une histoire naissance
de Miss France hier
je veux t'amuser
dans les coulisses elle m'a dit vous
aurez pas vu mon manteau en fait quand
elle parle de son manteau elle parle de
son cœur
commence à devenir gênant
demander ses coordonnées son numéro elle
m'a donné un mail c'est contact arobase
orange.fr
alors c'est
quoi
celle que je n'ai pas encore vécu
[Rires]
c'est vrai
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai j'ai pas mis chez moi hier
c'est qui
votre mec ou un ami
de toute manière il sait que il y a un
truc entre nous
je peux accepter si c'est Cyril
les couples qui font ça qui se font la
Wishlist c'est-à-dire la liste que tu tu
dis ça tu peux y aller si tu as le droit
d'y aller
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
Cyril
elle va faire elle va faire comme ça
dans le sable alors que Siri et quand tu
feras le sable derrière a marqué
augmentation
ça c'est magnifique c'est l'amour c'est
vrai
c'est
[Musique]
qui
Roger est en fin de vie
chaque jour est un jour de prime
[Rires]
si vous avez un nom écrire Alsace
elle est à la plage
[Applaudissements]
une lumière une intellectuelle
ben oui bien sûr
non mais attendez ça va c'est très
gentil
[Rires]
il se passe des choses entre nous
[Applaudissements]
comment on dit c'est trop magnifique
merci vraiment bravo
merci combien de fois voilà combien de
fois
j'aimerais savoir combien d'invention
vous avez eu
le temps de répondre
comme Isabelle
[Musique]
[Rires]
mais j'ai 47 ans
37 ans
[Rires]
Mykonos
[Applaudissements]
ah c'est bon